حزبه اردوغان يقيموا اداء الجوله الاولى
وانباء عن اقاله لنائبه بسبب سوء النتائج
[موسيقى]
انظمه الدفاع الجوي الاوكراني تتصدى
لهجمات روسيه وانفجارات تدوي في كييف
معين عبد الملك يؤكد للسفراء الاوروبيين
ان الحوثي غير مستعد للسلام رغم تنازلات
حكومته
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله صباحكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الاخباريه من العربيه عقدت لجنه
التنفيذيه للمركزيه لحزب العداله والتنميه
التركي اجتماعا برئاسه زعيم الحزب الرئيس
رجب طيب اردوغان في العاصمه انقره
الاجتماع الذي انعقد بعيدا عن وسائل
الاعلام واستغرق ثلاث ساعات خصص لتقييم
الانتخابات البرلمانيه والرئاسيه الاخيره
التي شهدتها تركيا كما ناقشت تحضيرات
اللازمه للجوله الثانيه من الانتخابات في
الثامن والعشرين من مايو الجاري
كان اردوغان قال في بيان الله ان شعبه
انجز انتخابات الرئاسه التركيه والتي تعد
على حد وصفه واحده من الانتخابات الاكثر
مشاركه في تاريخ تركيا مؤكدا ان الاصوات
التي حصل عليها ستضاعف وسيشهد فوزا
تاريخيا في جوله الاعاده
وبخصوص منافس اردوغان كمال وافادت مصادر
تركيا معارضه انه طلب من نائبه الاستقاله
بسبب ادائه السلبي في هذه الانتخابات
كالجدار اوغلوقه في مقطع نشر عبر على
حسابه في الفيديو قال فيه انه سيقاتل حتى
النهايه على حد وصفه
من جهته ذكر المرشح الرئيسي سنان اوغان
انه سيعلن خلال يومين عن المرشح الذي
سيدعمه اضف اوجان ان هناك خطوط حمراء
وشروط على راسها مكافحه الارهاب والابتعاد
عن الاحزاب السياسيه التي تدعمها
التنظيمات الارهابيه بالاضافه الى ترحيل
اللاجئين
يبدو ان الانتخابات تتجه نحو اجراء جوله
ثانيه ومن سيحسمهاهم القومي من الاتراك
واتباع كمال اتاتورك ايها الاصدقاء
الاعزاء امامنا 15 يوما اضافيه صعبه وخلال
هذه الفتره وفي حال انتهت الانتخابات
بالنتائج الحاليه وذهبنا الى جوله ثانيه
فسوف نبذل قصار جهودنا لجعل هذه العمليه
الانتخابيه مفيده لامه وبلادنا وفي هذه
الاثناء لا نقول اننا سوف ندعم طرفا دون
سواه
سنانوغان المرشح الثالث في الانتخابات
التركيه اعلن عن مطالبه السياسيه والتي
على اساسها سيقدم دعمه لاحد المرشحين
الرئيسيين
شروطه لترجيح كفه اردوغان او كليتش
داروغلو
اوغان حصل على مليونين وثمانمائه الف صوت
بنسبه خمسه.2%
على اردوغان اعاده اللاجئين وبقائهم خط
احمر بالنسبه لنا
دعم كريستيانو مرهون بعدم تقديمه تنازلات
للاكراد
القوميون الاتراك والاتاتوكيون ستكون لهم
كلمه حاسمه في جوله الاعاده
سنتشاور مع قاعده ناخبين قبل التوصل لقرار
حول جوله الاعاده
اسبوعان حاسمان يفصلان اردوغان وكالجدار
اوغلو عن جوله ختاميه تقرر من سيحكم تركيا
كيف سيكسب المتنافسان مزيدا من الاصوات
للظفر بهذا السباق
اذا اسبوعان حاسم ان يفصلان
اردوغانو عن جوله ختاميه تقرر من سيحكم
تركيا للفتره المقبله في جوله انتخابات
رئاسيه ثانيه تعد الاولى في تاريخ تركيا
التي تتزامن طبعا ويتزامن اجراؤها مع
الذكرى المئه لتاسيس البلاد كجمهوريه عقب
انهيار الامبراطوريه العثمانيه نسبه
المشاركه مشاهدينا كانت قياسيه وغير
مسبوقه وصلت الى
89% ولكن ما الذي سيفعله اردوغان خلال
هذين الاسبوعين لاقناع الناخبين بضروره
استمراره رئيسا للبلاد اولا يواجه الرجل
اي اردوغان صعوبات وتحديات لجذب كتله
ناخبه جديده تحسم المنافسه لصالحه لان
اولويه ان ناخذ التركيه اليوم هي مواجهه
الصعوبات الاقتصاديه والمعيشيه التي فشلت
فيها سياسات الغير معهوده اقتصاديا وهنا
يراهن اردوغان على شعبيته بين الناخبين
الريفيين والطبقه العامله والمتدينين
الذين ينسبون اليه الفضل بتطوير البلاد
وتعزيز مكانتها الدوليه خلال العشرين سنه
الماضيه ايضا سيعمل اردوغان على استقطاب
اصوات مناصري المرشح الثالث وهو سنان
اوغان الحاصل بحسب النتائج الاوليه
للانتخابات على 5% من الاصوات بحسب طبعا
النتائج الرسميه حيث من المرجح ان يفضله
اتباع اوجان القوميين اليمينيين تقول هنا
صحيفه نيويورك هذا كان عن اردوغان ولكن
ماذا عن اوغلو اوغلو هو مرشح المعارضه
سيستغل نقاط ضعف خصمه اردوغان لكسب اصوات
مناصريه والمترددين ايضا كما سيعمل زعيم
المعارضه لتعزيز خطابه الانتخ ابيه
والاجتماعي والاقتصادي الذي نجح فيه الى
حد كبير بنيل ثقه الاتراك بطبيعه الحال
لن ينسى ورقته الرابحه والتي عززت طبعا
حضوره وصوتت لصالحه خلال مختلف المحطات
الانتخابيه واعطته هذه المره 20% من
الاصوات الناخبه هذه الورقه هي الاكراد
طبعا
الاول لاعب كره قدم كان يطمح لاكمال
مسيرته الاحترافيه والثاني موظف حكومي
وكلاهما يتنافسان الان على رئاسه تركيا
رجب طيب اردوغان وكيل جدار اوغلو كل بدا
حياته بعيدا عن السياسه لتسوقهما الاقدار
للتنافس على الوصول الى قيمتها
[موسيقى]
كان ابوه قبطان بحريا لكنه عشق كره القدم
تمتع رجب طيب اردوغان بموهبه كرويه لافته
في الاعداداديه والثانويه لعب لصالح نادي
جامع الرياضي مقابل الف ليره شهريا اطلق
عليه اصدقائه لقب الامام بيكنباور كابورا
هو نمت مهاراته وتلقى عروضا من انديه اسكي
وفنر بهجه لكن والده عارض الامر
بدات في الرابعه عشر بلعب كره القدم في
الحي كنت وقتها طالبا في المرحله الثانويه
وكنت اتدرب في اكاديميه اسطنبول لكره
القدم ايضا بعد الانتهاء من المدرسه حاولت
دخول كليه التربيه الرياضيه واحتراف كره
القدم لكن والدي رحمه الله اعترض ومنعني
من اجل اكمال الدراسه ولم اتمكن من احتراف
كره القدم
منافسه في الانتخابات كمال كلجدار اوغلو
ولد بمنطقه ريفيه شرق الاناضول لعائله
علويه كان والده موظفا حكوميا فسار على
سير ابيه عمل محاسبا ثم تدرج في الوظائف
الحكوميه الى ان اصبح رئيسا لمؤسسه الضمان
الاجتماعي ساقت الاقدار الرجلين من عالم
الرياضه والوظيفه الى دهاليز السياسه حتى
المنافسه على رئاسه تركيا
ومع ذلك ما زال اردوغان لا يفوت فرصه الا
واظهر فيها مهاراته الرياضيه كذلك
الذي نشر صوره في المطبخ كموظف عادي يساعد
زوجته في الاعمال المنزليه
[موسيقى]
تمكنت انظمه الدفاع الجوي الاوكرانيه من
صدها هجمات جويه روسيه على اماكن اخرى
بحسب مسؤولين اوكرانيين ذكرت مصادر
اوكرانيا انفجارات وقعت في احياء عده
بالعاصمه في الساعات الاولى من صباح اليوم
دون تقديم معلومات عن حجم الخسائر فيما
اوضح رئيس بلديه كييف التالي كلينشكو ان
الحطام الناجم عن الانفجارات سقط على
حديقه للحيوانات في كييف
تعهد رئيس الوزراء البريطانيه
بمئات الطائرات من دون طيار بعيده المدى
ومجموعه متنوعه من الصواريخ ليخرج
بمكاسب عديده من جولته الاوروبيه خاصه في
ظل خططه لتوسيع الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد
حزمه عسكريه جديده ستسلمها لندن الى
القوات الاوكرانيه للدفاع عن اراضيها ضد
روسيا وطرد عناصرها من المناطق التي
احتلتها منذ بدء موسكو حمله عسكريه العام
الماضي رساله بريطانيه حملت طمانه الشعب
الاوكراني والرئيس الاوكراني الذي حل ضيفا
في زياره خاطفه لبيت من جهه وتحذيرا
لموسكو من جهه اخرى
من المهم ان يعرف الكريم اننا سنستمر في
دعم اوكرانيا على المدى الطويل سنظل
صامدين في تقديم المساعده لاوكرانيا ليس
فقط الان لاستعاده اراضيها الشرعيه ولكن
ايضا لضمان ان اوكرانيا لديها وسيله
للدفاع عن نفسها
مئات صواريخ والانظمه الدفاعيه الجويه بما
فيها طائرات بدون طيار بعيده المدى
ستوفرها الحكومه البريطانيه لاوكرانيا
وتراها لندن ضروريه في مقاومه كياف حربا
فظيعه فرضتها موسكو على
الاوكرانيينسكي ممتن للدعم البريطاني
المتواصل لبلده حتى قبل بدايه الحمله
العسكريه لكنه يضغط للحصول على الطائرات
حربيه
تحدثنا اليوم عن تزويدنا بمقاتلات والامر
مهم جدا لاننا لا نتحكم في اجواءنا وهذا
معروف كوننا شركاء حقيقيين يعرف كل تفاصيل
ما يجري في ساحه المعركه ونريد انشاء
تحالف للحصول على الطائرات الحربيه وانا
متفائل جدا في هذا الخصوص لان هناك قرارات
مهمه ستتخذ قريبا
فيما المناقشات مستمره اكد سوناك ان بلاده
ستكون جزءا من تحالف دوليا لتقديم الدعم
الذي يطالب به زيلينسكي اجتماع الزعيمين
ياتي بعد ان وافقت الحكومه البريطانيه
الاسبوع الماضي على ارسال صواريخ بعيده
المدى لاول مره الى جانب الدعم العسكري
بقيمه مليارين وثلاثه مئه مليون جنيه
تعاهدت به لندن العام الماضي
لا توجد خطط لارسال طائرات حربيه بريطانيه
لاوكرانيا لكن وزاره الدفاع اكدت انها
ستدرب الطيارين اوكرانيين على طائرات اف
16 التي لا تستخدم في سلاح الجو الملكي
والحزمه العسكريه الجديده تاكيد على
مواصله وقوف بريطانيا مع الشعب الاوكراني
وحمايه اراضيه مصطفى زارو العربيه لندن
سخر الرئيس هو مجموعه فاغنر روسيه
من تقرير صحيفه واشنطن بوست افاد بانه عرض
على كييف معلومات حول مواقع القوات
الروسيه مقابل انسحابها من باخموت ووصف
تقرير بالمضحك مرشحا ان يكون افراد من
النخبه الروسيه وراءه اما الكرملين فوصف
المعلومات التي نشرتها واشنطن بوست
بالمضلله
اشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعد الفاصل
محكمه تونسيه مختصه بقضايا الارهاب تقضي
بالسجن عاما لراشد الغنوشي زعيم حركه
النهضه
اهلا بكم من جديد استقبل وزير الخارجيه
السعودي الامير فيصل بن فرحان نظيرته
الالمانيه ان لينا بيربوك في جده اعربت عن
شكري وتقدير بلادها لما قامت به المملكه
من عمليات اجراء لرعايه المانيا من
السودان منوهه بالكفاءه العاليه للجهات
السعوديه في نجاح هذه العمليات عقد
الجانبان جلسه مباحثات رسميه تطرقت للسبل
تعزيز جهود البلدين في ارساء دعائم السلام
بالمنطقه والعالم
ادانا الامين العام لمجلس التعاون جاسم
البديوي تعرض مقر سكن رئيس المكتب العسكري
في سفاره الكويت في الخرطوم للاقتحام
والتخريب شدد الامين العام على ضروره
احترام الاتفاقيات الدوليه والاعراف
الدبلوماسيه التي تضمن حرمه وسلامه مقرات
البعثات الدبلوماسيه وداع جميع الاطراف في
السودان الى اتخاذ الاجراءات الفوريه
اللازمه لحمايه الدبلوماسيين والمقرات
الدبلوماسيه كانت الخارجيه الكويتيه اعلنت
عن تعرض مقر سكن رئيس المكتب العسكري
بالسفاره دوله الكويت لدى الخرطوم
للاقتحام والتخريب واعربت الوزاره في بيان
لها عن ادانه واستنكار دوله الكويت
للاعتداء الذي تعرض له مقر رئيس المكتب
العسكري ولكافه اشكال العنف والتخريب
بدورها اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه والشؤون
المغتربين تعرض مبنى السفاره الاردنيه في
الخرطوم لاقتحام وتخريب عربه الخارجيه عن
اداناتها واستنكارها للاعتداء الذي تعرض
له مبنى السفاره ولكافه اعمال العنف
والتخريب خاصه تلك التي تستهدف المباني
الدبلوماسيه وتنتهك سيادتها كما اشارت
الخارجيه الاردنيه الى ان البعثه في
السودان بخير وانها موجوده في مدينه
بورسودان
شهر على هذا الحال السودان يختنق فوضى لم
تفرق حرب لم تصدها حصانه ولا دبلوماسيه
تعدت اسوار السفارات والملحقات الثقافيه
الاردن المتضرر الاخير اعلن اقتحامه
وتخريب مقر سفارته في الخرطوم اما في
السادس من مايو حادثه اعتداء على موكب
تابع للسفاره التركيه لدى الخرطوم
قبل اقل من اسبوعين شهدت الملحقيه
الثقافيه السعوديه في السودان اقتحاما
واستيلاء على ممتلكاتها
وابل من الرصاص تعرضت له سياره مصفحه تتبع
للسفاره الامريكيه في الخرطوم
كما جرى الاعتداء على مقر اقامه سفير
الاتحاد الاوروبي في السودان
فيما تعرض مقر البعثه الدبلوماسيه
الفرنسيه لهجوم ادى الى تاجيل اجلال رعايه
فرنسيين
اطلاق الاعيره الناريه طالع ايضا السفاره
الهنديه
حوادث الاعتداء على السفارات هذه عاده ما
كانت توريبك عمليات الاجلاء او تؤجلها غير
انها شاهده على خرق واضح لهدن لم تعرف
للصمود طريقا غذاء السالم العربيه
طالب تجمع العاملين بقطاع النفط السوداني
كلا من قوه الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني
بانهاء الحرب في البلاد وعدم تدمير
المنشات النفطيه اكد بيان التجمع ان قوات
الدعم السريع لا تزال تسيطر على مصفاه
الخرطوم ما خلق ازماتا في التوزيع على
امتداد البلاد اضاف البيان ان مبنى رئاسه
شركه النيل الكبرى لعمليات البترول تعرض
ايضا لقذيفه ادت لاحداث خسائر بالغه
ابرز الاحداث في السودان منذ بدء القتال
بين الجيش وقوات الدعم نستعرضها في هذا
التقرير
ابرز احداث النزاع في السودان في الخامس
عشر من ابريل وبعد ايام قليله من تاجيل
جديد لتوقيع اتفاق سياسي بدا النزاع بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع في السادس عشر
من الشهر الماضي اعلن برنامج الاغذيه
العالمي تعليق عمله في السودان بعد مقتل
عدد من عمال الاغاثه في دارفور اليومان
الثالث والرابع من النزاع شهدا خرقه
اثنتين معلنتين في الثاني والعشرين من
ابريل اصبحت السعوديه اول دوله تجلي
مدنيين من السودان ولحقتها دول اخرى في
الخامس والعشرين من ابريل دخلت حيز
التنفيذ هدنه لثنتين وسبعين ساعه ببساطه
سعوديه وامريكيه تلتها هدن اخرى في نفس
اليوم اعلن احمد هارون وهو احد مساعدي
الرئيس السابق عمر البشير قراره من السجن
رفقه مسؤولين سابقين اخرين في السادس
والعشرين من ابريل اكد الجيش ان البشير
محتجز لدى الشرطه القضائيه
تم تمديد وقف اطلاق النار لاثنتين وسبعين
ساعه اضافيه في الثامن والعشرين من ابريل
لكن القتال العنيف السمر محادثات جده بدات
في السادس من مايو برعايه سعوديه وامريكيه
وبعد مفاوضات لسته ايام وقع الجانبان
اعلانا يضمن السماح بمرور امن للمدنيين
لمغادره مناطق القتال ودخول المساعدات
الانسانيه
دعا حكيم واقليمي دارفور المنظمات الدوليه
والاقليميه والمحليه الى تقديم المساعده
الطارئه للمحتاجين في مدينه الجنينه والتي
تشهد اشتباكات قبليه وضعا انسانيا متدهورا
بندع معنا المنظمات المحليه والاقليميه
والدوليه جميعا بان تسعفنا وتساعدنا
بانسياب المواط
الطبيه وتحرك معانا الى الامام لوصول الى
جنينه في اقرب وقت ممكن وفي نفس الوقت
ندعو برضو بئس العموميه اليونيتامس بان
توجه كثير من المواد الان موجوده مقدسه في
بورسودان وخاصه الرئيس
بان يوجه لنا كثير من هذه المواد ونحن
نسعى للتامين مطار جنينه ومطار الفاشر
بانزال هذه المواد لنا في اقرب وقت ممكن
قبل ذلك قالت لجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر
ان المرافق الصحيه في السودان على وشك
الانهيار اضافتنا مرافق الرعايه الصحيه في
السودان تعاني منذ اسابيع من نقص
الامدادات والعلاج مشيره الى توقف اكثر من
70% من المستشفيات عن العمل
اكد رئيس الوزراء اليمني معين عبد الملك
حرص حكومته على اتاحه الفرصه للجهود
الراميه لانهاء الحرب في بلاده جاء ذلك
خلال اجتماع لمعين عبد الملك مع بعثه
وسفراء عدد من دول الاتحاد الاوروبي لدى
اليمن حيث اشار رئيس الوزراء للتنازلات
التي قدمتها الشرعيه في مسار الهدنه
بالرغم من حصار الحوثيين لتعز وانتهاكاتهم
المتكرره التي تعمق معاناه اليمنيين هذا
حذر رئيس الوزراء اليمني من خطوره تغاضي
المجتمع الدولي عن الاجراءات الاحاديه
التي امارسها الحوثيون ضد اقتصاد البلاد
والبنوك بالمناطق الخاضعه للسيطرتهم
في تونس قضت محكمه مختصه في قضايا الارهاب
بسجن راشد الغنوشي رئيس حركه النهضه لمده
عام وتغريمه ذكرت المحكمه ان الغنوشي
اودينا غيابيا بوصف الاجهزه الامنيه
بالطواغيت الامر الذي يندرج ضمن افعال من
مجرد او افعال مجرمه وفقا للقانون مجربه
لدى بيان صادر عن الجيش الباكستاني عقب
اجتماع ضمه
التي تعرضت لها مرافقه وتوعد مخططي
ومنافذي هذه الاعتداءات بالمحاكمه وفق
القوانين الباكستانيه والقانون العسكري
وللمره الثانيه خلال اقل من اسبوع مثل
رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خان امام
القضاء مجددا للرد على الاتهامات المواجهه
اليه بعد اعتقاله واحتجازه الاسبوع الماضي
بشان التخطيط لاعمال العنف التي اعقبت
توقيفه مثل خان امام محكمه في لاهور للرد
على الاتهامات الموجهه اليه بالتخطيط
لاعمال العنف التي اعقبت توقيفه بحسب احد
محاميه
وقد توفد الاف المحتجين الباكستانيين وشق
طريقهم نحو مقر المحكمه العليا في اسلام
اباد مطالبين باستقاله رئيس المحكمه
لقراره الافراج عن رئيس الوزراء السابق
عمرا خان فيما ندد مؤتمر لكبار قاده الجيش
بهجمات انصار خان على منشات عسكريه
والتعهد بمعاقبه كل من لهم علاقه بالعنف
وفقا للقوانين المدنيه والعسكريه
هجمات القرش على البشر قد تكون امرا
معتادا ولكن تزايودها وارتفاع وثيرتها في
مناطق مختلفه من العالم يدفع الى التساؤل
عن الاسباب وما اذا كان للتغير المناخ دور
في ذلك
هذه لقطه لهجوم قرش على زورق كاياك قرابه
الشواطئ هاواي وهذه الاريد فتاه امريكيه
في الثالثه عشر من عمرها تسببت لها سمكه
قرش بجراح غائره
اما هذا الشاطئ الهادئ فهو مسرح لعمليه
بحث تقوم بها الشرطه الاستراليه على جثه
راكب امواج هاجمته سمكه قرش ضخمه ما يجمع
بين هذه الهجمات رغم بعدها الجغرافي هو
تقارب تواريخها فكلها حدثت في الاسبوع
الثاني من شهر مايو 2023
هذه الوتيره المرتفعه لهجمات القرش فسرها
بعض العلماء بكونها مرتبطه بتاثيرات
المناخ التي تدفع باسماك القرش للاقتراب
من الشواطئ نظرا لتناقص كميات ما تقتات
عليه هذه الاسماك مما يدفعها الى البحث عن
مصادر مختلفه للطعام من جهه اخرى يقول
عالم الاحياء البحريه البريطاني ديفيد
جاكوبي ان تصرفات البشر هي سبب ارتفاع
هجمات القرش حيث ان الصيد الجائر واقتراب
مرتدي الشواطئ من المياه متوسطه العمق
والعميقه سباحه وعبر الزوارق الصغيره تكون
مستفزه لهذه الاسماك التي توصف بكونها
عنيفه ولكنها في الواقع هي التي تتعرض
لهجوم بشري ان اسم ماسي العربيه
في نهايه نشره تذكير بابرز العناوين
حزب اردوغان يقيم اداء الجوله الاولى
وانباء عن اقاله
لنائبه بسبب سوء النتائج
انظمه الدفاع الجوي الاوكراني تتصدى
لهجمات روسيه وانفجارات تدوي فكيف
للسفراء الاوروبيين ان الحوثي غير مستعد
للسلام رغم تنازلات حكومته
مشاهدينا بهذا وصلنا الى نهايه هذه الفتره
الاخباريه شكرا لكم على كرم المتابعه في
امان الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات